a huge day in news President Trump
making a very gutsy call on Israel and
Jerusalem
Al Franken finally looks like he's on
his way out the door and serious
controversy still brewing over Roy Moore
in Alabama with Steve Ben and the
execrable getting into office I'll
explain I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show so as always of late the
news is just coming out of the firehose
and there is an almost no way to imbibe
enough of it to really stay abreast of
it there's so much news breaking so
quickly President Trump about to make a
major announcement on Jerusalem as
Israel's capital long-overdue at least
decades overdue so that's a great thing
Plus Al Franken on his way out I will
explain why that's happening did
Democrats suddenly discover principal
not really but does that excuse
Republicans for having abandoned
principal not really and speaking of
that will talk about Roy Moore in the
latest from down south but first I want
to say thank you to our sponsors over at
helix sleep so as I have said many times
I am not good at sleep great a lots of
things not good at sleep or at least I
wasn't until I got a helix sleep
mattress the way it works over at helix
sleep is they actually customize a
mattress for you go over to their
website and helix sleep comm slash Ben
and you take a quiz and it gives you a
profile you know how much do you weigh
how is what's your body shape do you
like to sleep on your side your back
don't sleep on your stomach do you want
the mattress to be breathable or firm
you know all the different settings and
then they send it to in the mail you
open the box it's a foam mattress when
you unwrap it it just inflates right in
front of you and it's ready to go it's
such a nice mattress that we took a much
more expensive mattress from our room
and we actually put it in the other room
so that we could use our helix sleep
mattress my wife absolutely adores this
mattress everyone who tries it likes it
in and here's the good news if you're
one of the few who doesn't
well you don't lose anything because you
can try it for 100 nights and if you
don't love it they will pick it up and
refund you in full the mattress arrives
direct to your door and a week shipping
is completely free go to helix sleep
calm slash Ben right now helix sleep
calm slash Ben they'll get 50 bucks
towards your custom mattress that helix
sleep calm / Ben for 50 bucks off your
order
again helix sleep calm / Ben and it's
less expensive than other mattresses
because you're getting it online anyway
so it's pretty great so yeah 50 bucks
off again helix sleep calm / Ben for 50
bucks off okay so we begin with
President Trump making a major
announcement it's supposed to happen in
about 45 minutes here it's supposed to
happen at 10:00
and that is in it's an amazing thing
he's supposed to the rumor is should not
just announce that the United States is
view now officially is that Jerusalem is
the eternal capital of Israel but also
that he's going to move the embassy from
Tel Aviv to Jerusalem this is a great
and brave thing to do and I'm gonna give
you a multiplicity of reasons why this
is a great and brave thing to do by
President Trump and not something
frankly that I expected from President
Trump I may be the statement about
Jerusalem being Israel's capital because
lots of presidents have said similar
stuff but not the statement about moving
the embassy because that's always been
politically dicey so the law is and it
has been since 1995 Congress passed a
law and they passed it overwhelmingly
that that said that Israel's capital was
Jerusalem and that it should remain
undivided that law was passed in 93 to 5
in the Senate and 374 to 37 in the house
in 1995 for years the president has been
waving that law Bush did it Clinton did
it Obama did it none of them would
actually build the embassy because they
supposedly didn't want to undercut the
peace process but really what it was
about is they they wanted to cater to
and surrender to the whims of the
Palestinian Authority a terrorist group
as well as other Muslim nations that
were propping up that terrorist group
this was stupid policy so let's begin
with the facts okay
Jerusalem is was and will be the eternal
capital of Israel Jerusalem is only
important the only reason you've heard
of it the only reason anyone cares about
it is because the Jews made it important
okay that is literally the only reason
otherwise it's just another city in the
Middle East there's both the capital of
the Kingdom of Israel and the site of
the temple it was the wellspring of
Judaic thought for literally millennia
okay when I pray three times a day
Jerusalem is mentioned frequently in
those prayers both Christianity and
Islam value Jerusalem because Judaism
did first the dream of Jerusalem has
animated the Jewish people for its
entire existence the most famous case
being in Psalms 137 where it says if I
forget the Jerusalem may my right hand
forget it's skill Jerusalem is mentioned
literally hundreds of times in what we
call Tanakh that be the Old Testament so
that includes the Torah as well as the
prophets and the writings the only
reason that it's not mentioned
specifically in the five books of Moses
is because at that time it was actually
two cities one called youru and the
other called shalom and then it was put
together into yerushalayim right it
became one city sort of like Buddha and
past became Buddha past in any case it's
always been the center of Judaic
thinking it's always been the holiest
spot in Judaism
Jerusalem by contrast has not mentioned
one single time anywhere in the Quran if
Jews don't have a claim to Jerusalem and
this is the root of why Muslims want to
declare that Jews don't have a claim
also it's the root of why the papacy has
been really split on Jerusalem right
there there have been Pope's who have
been Pro the idea of Jewish sovereignty
in Jerusalem and then the current Pope
says that it should be internationalized
which is just insipid because if you
have Muslim rule over Jerusalem that
means nobody else gets to come in and
again Jewish sovereignty over a Jewish
holy site seems like the basic the basic
notion is just moral especially since
Jews have maintained the holy sites of
both Muslims and Christians in Jerusalem
if Jews don't have a claim to Jerusalem
they don't claim to anything they've
claims to nothing if they don't claim to
Jerusalem there's no claim to tel-aviv
there's no claim to Haifa there's no
claim to Yaffa
yeah oh there isn't there's no claim to
Akko there's no claim to any other city
in Israel if you don't have a claim to
Jerusalem
hey that's fact number one and Trump is
recognizing an established fact on the
ground number two as I say Congress has
long recognized Jerusalem as Israel's
capital not just in 1995 this year
because you're seeing a bunch of Senate
Democrats now oh how dare Trump how
terrible for president Trump who says
how could president Trump - he's gonna
lead to a conflagration well so he jerks
were saying literally six months ago in
June there was a resolution that was
passed on the floor of the Senate it was
passed 90 to nothing zero dissenting
votes 90 to nothing saying that Israel's
remain it's it's eternal capital is
Jerusalem and it should remain undivided
okay third point recognizing Jerusalem
as Israel's capital recognizes Israeli
sovereignty hey Israel gets to negotiate
on its own behalf it's not up to the
United States or any other foreign
nation to negotiate on Israel's behalf
with regard to its own capital to
understand how important this is imagine
that foreign bodies came in and told the
United States that we had to give up
Washington DC now imagine that
Washington DC wasn't just a city that
was built on a swamp so that we didn't
have to build it inside a state it had
been divinely ordained by God for the
American people okay that's how
important Jerusalem is to the Jews it is
the basis of all Judaic thought and all
Judaic history and people who are saying
they're gonna force Israel into making
these concessions it's immoral
okay Israel gets to make a call on its
own okay recognizing Jerusalem as
Israel's capital will minimize violence
you're hearing a lot of myths today from
the left oh look
it violence terrorism is coming first of
all the Palestinian Authority is was and
always will be a terrorist density Hamas
is was will be a terrorist entity as
Lama ki HOD is was will be a terrorist
entity all of the people threatening
violence today we're anti-semites
yesterday they'll be anti-semites
tomorrow they were terrorists yesterday
and there will be terrorists tomorrow if
it's a day ending and why the
Palestinian Authority is interested in
murdering Jews in terror attacks the
same is true of course of Hamas the idea
that the Jerusalem is the sticking point
in negotiations is just not true one
thing that will happen by recognizing
Israel sovereignty over Jerusalem is
that the Palestinians may lose hope that
they can pry Jerusalem from Israel by
pressuring the United States or
pressuring the west through terror
attack maybe they'll finally recognized
reality and they'll recognize this is
just not going to be part of the
negotiations okay fifth the United
States should not be bullied by
terrorists period anywhere all over the
world the idea that the United States
ever signed off on the Oslo Accords is
ridiculous Israel never should have
either the idea that you're going to be
blackmailed by people that you're they
were gonna say to you you know if you
just give us land then we'll stop
murdering your children blackmail used
to be a violation of both domestic and
international law then it was made into
the centerpiece of American foreign
policy in the Middle East for 20 years
and the centerpiece of Israel
Palestinian policy for 25 years it never
worked
Oslo is a full-scale disaster as it
turns out the person who's trying to
blackmail you wants the money okay they
don't want to turn back over the the
Doug regretting material if somebody
steals the porn off your computer and
then they want to blackmail you because
they have the porn on your computer
their goal is not to give you back the
porn on your computer their goal is to
continue getting money out of you
okay Oslo was always a blackmail deal
anything that blackmail deal is good for
the United States it's not caving to
terrorism also as I say
recognizing reality makes peace more
possible so a big underdeveloped piece
of news that came out last week is that
the Saudi monarchy reportedly summoned
Palestinian leadership and told them to
support a peace deal with the Israelis
not only that that deal would retain
major Israeli settlement blocs prevent
the establishment of a standing
Palestinian army and leave the PA
without Jerusalem as a Palestinian
capital in other words the Saudis know
about this already
everybody is claiming all the Saudis are
so mad the Saudis are not mad the Saudis
knew about this
they were paving the way about this
Jared Kushner over the White House I'm
sure was talking to Saudi Arabia you
know two weeks ago people were saying he
Cal telling to the Saudis now they're
saying he's stabbing the Saudis in the
back is it possible that maybe he was
talking with the Saudis is it possible
that the new anti-iranian alliance
Jordan Egypt Saudi Arabia Israel that
that Alliance is strengthened by this
status being clarified that we can
finally get this issue off the table
then now that this is clear that the
United States recognizes the truth that
Jerusalem is Israel's capital that Saudi
Arabia and Jordan and Egypt are just
gonna have to accept it if they want
this alliance against the Iranians as I
say this also means continuing the
anti-iranian alliance and forwarding the
anti-iranian alliance right in 1991
during the Gulf War George HW Bush faced
a choice
Israel was hit by Scud missiles by
Saddam Hussein and Israel wanted to join
the coalition to topple Saddam Hussein
and the or at least you push Saddam
Hussein out of Kuwait and HW said to the
Israelis don't get involved because
you'll fracture our coalition it was a
bad move HW should have said sure get
involved and then he should have said to
the Saudis you don't like it well then
fine deal with it yourself you don't
like Israel being on your side that's
your problem he could have forced a
peace through mutual Assurance he could
have forced a peace through mutual
recognition of common interest and
that's exactly what's happening in the
aftermath of Iran okay so I wanted to
lay out all of those reasons to show you
that what Trump is doing here is not
just immoral it is also smart I also
want to point out here that all of the
talk about how this recognition is going
to cause violence violence in Jerusalem
has long predated any of these
negotiations let me give you a brief
history of Jerusalem here so you have
more information today than you did
yesterday okay
in 1929 before there was in Israel
before there was Jewish sovereignty over
Jerusalem before there was Arab
sovereignty over Jerusalem it was
British Mandate Palestine right was the
British running Jerusalem and there were
riots in Jerusalem by Arabs against Jews
17 people were killed why because Jews
had the temerity to bring chairs to the
Wailing Wall to the western wall the
second holiest site in Judaism the
holiest site in Judaism is the Temple
Mount Jews are still not allowed up on
the Temple Mount because the Dome of the
rock is up there and the Muslims run it
so Jews will allow Muslims into Jewish
areas but Muslims will never allow Jews
into Jewish areas which is why Jews
should run the place and not Muslims
okay but in 1929 before any of this was
an issue for any of it existed right at
that time the Jews just
to bring chairs for the elderly and
infirm to the western wall so Arabs
rioted and killed 17 people then they
ride in have Ronan Hebron and they
killed 60 more Jews there's a report
from the British here's what it
described quote Arabs in Hebron made a
most ferocious attack on the Jewish
ghetto and on isolated Jewish houses
lying outside the crowded quarters of
the town more than 60 Jews including
many women and children were murdered
more than 50 were wounded okay fast
forward to 1948 so Israel accepts the
deal the partition deal from the UN the
UN was gonna partition Jerusalem there's
gonna divide Jerusalem instead the Arabs
blockaded Jerusalem cut off all the
roads and tried to basically put the
Jews in Jerusalem the largest most
Jewish city in Israel under siege
the Israelis at the cost of thousands of
lives finally broke through but East
Jerusalem remained in Arab hands in
Muslim hands and not only that so did
the Western Wall so did the Temple Mount
so was everything peaceful was
everything fine when the Arabs are
running it the answer was no of course
because in 1964 while the Arabs were
still running East Jerusalem and Jordan
had sovereignty over East Jerusalem the
Palestine Liberation Organization was
formed that would later become the
Palestinian Authority that was Yasser
Arafat's group in 1964 their stated goal
the full destruction of the State of
Israel from the river to the sea
Palestine shall be free that was their
slogan okay that was well they were
running Jerusalem so anyone who says
that Jerusalem is the sticking point
Jerusalem is not the sticking point in
1967 Israel finally takes over East
Jerusalem and frees East Jerusalem by
the way when I say freeze I mean that
the Arab parts of East Jerusalem are
still run like an Arab dictatorship even
though Israel has sovereignty when I
visited Israel in 2001 this is middle
with Second Intifada when we came out in
East Jerusalem I had to be guarded by
Israeli soldiers if you are a Jew
walking from East Jerusalem Arab East
Jerusalem you know life is in danger if
you are an Arab a Muslim walking through
West Jerusalem no problems at all
because that's the way tyranny versus
democracy works
by the way Israel handed back controlled
the Temple Mount to the Islamic walk
which is a huge miscalculation Jews are
still not allowed to pray on the Temple
Mount if I went there and tried to pray
I'd be arrested in 1993 Israel agreed to
negotiate with the terrorists
Palestinian Authority including over
Jerusalem what happened massive uptick
in terror in 2000 at the Camp David
summit Israeli prime minister o hoot
Barak of the Israeli Labor Party offered
Palestinian terrorists Yasser Arafat
control over East Jerusalem and the
Temple Mount itself according to Bill
Clinton Arafat didn't even submit a
counteroffer he left the table and he
started the Second Intifada resulting in
the murder of over 700 Jews I was in
Israel when the spiral pizzeria was
bombed and I remember walking past the
ruins of the pizzeria in the center of
Jerusalem all of that after Israel had
offered East Jerusalem to the
Palestinians in 2008 Israeli Prime
Minister akuto merrick offered a new
Palestinian terrorist dictator mouth
would Abbas international control of
Jerusalem's Old City which would include
the holy sites not only that he also
offered some of Israeli lands who make
up for the Israeli settlements that have
been built an Israeli land strip that
would connect the Gaza Strip to Judea
and Samaria Abbas turned it down without
a counteroffer and then launched another
round of violence in coordination with
Hamas and Gaza so all of this talk about
how it's just Jerusalem that if we were
to solidify the status of Jerusalem this
would cause violence no Jerusalem is an
excuse for violence and if Jerusalem
were an Arab hands there would still be
violence because there was when it was
in Arab hands okay so now you have all
the background that you need on this
particular topic so don't believe any of
the mythology Trump is making a moral
move and a politically smart move and a
politically valuable move for American
policy in the Middle East okay so now I
want to move to another topic that topic
of course is Democrats so Democrats have
now decided that Al Franken has to go
it's actually kind of an amazing thing
right there they're now saying that is
seven senators I believe have come out
in the last hour and said that Al
Franken needs to go why because there
was a new allegation with regard to with
regard to Al Franken there was an aide
who said that he tried to force himself
on earth he tried to kiss her and then
when she refused then she then then he
said I'm an entertainer and I'm owed
this he denies this allegation doesn't
matter Democrats have decided to throw
him under the bus they're mostly
throwing him under the bus because they
want to push Republicans into a corner
with regard to Roy Moore they want to
say we have the moral high ground you
guys are backing Roy Moore still you
don't have the moral high ground
our Democrats really being honest about
this are Democrats really did they
really care that Al Franken sexually
abuses people not really
senator Kirsten Gillibrand like two
seconds ago was saying that he didn't
have to resign I'll show you in just a
second first I want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at stamps.com
so stam's comm is helping you save time
this holiday season it's a great way for
you not have to go to the post office
even like the post office post office is
great but if you
go stand in line at the post office you
want to be able to sit at your desk
prints all your postage you know where's
packages never have to go out and leave
your desk save time before the holidays
then stamps comb is made for you they
bring all the services of the US Postal
Service right to your finger trip tips
we use it here at daily wire buy and
prints official US postage for any
letter any package any class of mail
using your own computer and printer and
then the mailman comes and picks it up
they will even send you a digital scale
automatically calculating the exact
postage for you and they'll help you
decide the best class of mail too I use
stamps calm because it saves us time and
it saves us money right now you can
enjoy the stamps comm service with that
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus postage and a digital scale
without long term commitments go to
stamps calm click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in
Shapiro that stamps comm Shapiro and you
got again that four-week trial plus
postage and the digital scale no long
term commitments go check it out and
save yourself some time so kirsten
gillibrand today says al franken has to
go the senator has to leave that's how
what she was saying literally yesterday
here she was talking yesterday I believe
the women I believe that what they said
happened happened and I think there is a
reckoning and I think there needs to be
accountability and it needs to happen
now
better yes I'm telling you I am so angry
and frustrated and I'm not gonna say
that today but it is something that I'm
very troubled about ok so now of course
she says the Franken should step down so
yesterday yeah
on the Franken stepping down now of
course she wants Franken gone and this
of course is because she and other
Democrats are trying to seize the moral
high ground with regard to Roy Moore
they're saying Republicans will back
anybody up to an including an alleged
Shah molester but we won't support Al
Franken they waited you'll notice until
two days or the day after the RNC jumped
back in on the Roy Moore issue right
they waited until the day after and then
they say ok we'll dump Franken over the
side so this is a politically motivated
but doesn't mean it's wrong doesn't mean
it's immoral but it is politically
motivated and to ignore that is just
foolish you can see how politically
motivated it is when you look at when
you look at another topic right and that
topic of course is John Conyers so John
Conyers said yesterday that he was going
to retire he said he was retiring
effective immediately and then he
recommended that his son take over for
him so here
john conyers for the record for those
who may not have understood I heard what
you said is that you're very confident
in your legacy you are today at this
time at this moment in this period
preparing for your retirement a date in
which you are not prepared to announce
yes I I thank you for helping me get the
sense of focus putting my retirement
plans together and I will have more
about that very soon and I want everyone
to know how much I appreciate the
support
okay so Conyers says that he was
retiring yesterday you notice that the
radio host actually has to prod him to
retire right he forgot on this phone
call that he should retire because he
now old bat them but he also says that
he wants his son to fill in for him so
let me tell you little bit about his son
okay this just shows you the political
fiefdom that exists so when Democrats
say all were punishing Conyers we're
punishing Franken listen again it's
moral that these guys should go I don't
think more should sit in the Senate
right and this is not a matter of I'm
using this as what about ISM I think
more should go I think Franken should go
I think Conyers should go but you do
have to recognize the political
motivations that are at play here John
Conyers is leaving but he's leaving his
son in charge okay or he wants to his
son is John Conyers the third John
Conyers the third is a 27 year old guy
who has literally done nothing like I
literally don't know what he does for a
living no one knows what he does for a
living also he came out he's a big
defender of his dad saying that his dad
originally he said that his father was
completely clean he said it's
unfortunate to see him fight so long for
so many people and to automatically have
the allegations assumed to be true
unfortunately there's also this tape of
John Conyers the third who will be your
new Congress person from the city of
Detroit rapping about how his father was
a player living boy trying to make
history
[Music]
pick me again run around like a jitney
okay my momma 37 months at that
sentencing
I guess this grad socks in the cultural
appropriation and wearing that hat in
any case John Connors deterred your new
Congress person and this just shows you
that politics for so many Americans has
become a fiefdom right it's not a
punishment for John Conyers to step down
henry ii to step down and hand his crown
over to his son richard the lionheart
right that's not actually a thing and
and what i love about this is that
there's actually an intern acing battle
that's happening right now right so
Conyers the third wants to take over the
seat but so does his so does John
Connors grandnephew so Conyers three
wants to fight his own nephew for this
seat I assume that given the way that
history works John Conyers the third
will eventually take his nephew throw
him in the Tower of London and have him
killed Allah Richard the third but
that's the way these fiefdom ins work
John Conyers sat in the house for years
because we'd because there's this
tendency to believe and it's very
disturbing there's this tendency to
believe that our politicians are not our
representatives they don't represent us
they're our lords and ladies of the
manor they have their own fiefdom John
Conyers has his own fiefdom right in
2006 he was investigated by the house
for using and for telling three staffers
to basically be his personal servants
and babysitters and then forcing them to
work on state and local campaigns he
want 85% of the vote in his district
that year okay a couple of years later
his wife queen queen Monica read King
Conyers in queen Monica she served on
the Detroit City Council and she was
convicted of bribery she spent three
years in jail
okay Conyers himself was involved in
this he reversed his position on the
project that she was bribed to take to
get through the Conyers one 77% of the
vote in that election cycle and now he's
turning over his seat to his son so this
is how we think of our politicians
they're not there to represent us so you
know we don't have to worry about
whether they provide a good face for our
politics all they do is what we want
them to do and as long as they protect
us as long as they protect us from
invading Nobles then we are happy to pay
them an extra share of our harvest
basically the way we see people like
John Conyers and this holds true on both
sides of al this is why I think that so
many people seem untroubled by all the
Roy Moore stuff they've decided in their
heads that Roy Moore is a fine guy not
because they think he's a fine guy but
they feel like well he's the lord of the
manor
so you know he was taking his droit to
senior with with with a bunch of
sixteen-year-old girls but you know so
long as he protects my values so long as
he protects what I want is that really a
big deal Democrats as I say are using
this logic in order to tear down
Republicans and they're doing it quite
successfully Republicans by the way are
tearing themselves down pretty
successfully on this one they took the
worst possible position they abandoned
more and then they rushed back two more
just in time for this election cycle
after Trump endorsed him and in doing so
they reimbursed all of the worst things
about Roy Moore and so you can see the
Democrats are trying to run a we are the
we are the great clean party campaign
this is their new thing I'll show you
that in a second and I'll show you why
the Republicans are running right into
the teeth of it and it's gonna cause
them serious political harm first I want
to say thank you to our sponsors over at
Skillshare so Skillshare there's a way
for you to make your resume deeper and
better it's a way for you to ensure that
when you come up for a raise your bosses
say absolutely as opposed to losing you
because you're constantly growing your
skillset that's what Skillshare does
they have over three million members
more than 17,000 classes it is the
Netflix for online learning you can take
classes in graphic design social media
marketing digital illustration and more
they're taught by industry experts the
Skillshare classes experienced
professionals it's perfect if you're
looking to build your career or start
the side hustle of your dreams I've
taken both their watercolor class which
has deepened my emotions and also made
me a better painter but more importantly
I've been taking their social media
marketing and SEO classes which has
helped us out over here at Daily wire
Skillshare is giving my listeners a one
month free trial of unlimited access to
over 17,000 classes go to Skillshare
comm / Shapiro to start that free month
today skills shared comm slash Shapiro
to start that free month today go and
check it out once you start learning
you're not gonna want to stop Skillshare
calm / up here I'll make that resume
better make more money create a better
career for yourself that's what skill
shares for skill share calm / Shapiro
okay so so Doug Jones is jumping on the
we are clean bandwagon this is it this
is campaign now it's his entire
campaign because he can't win based on
his politics he's a Democrat in a state
that 66% Republican here is Doug Jones
the Democratic candidate in Alabama I
believe women are every bit as capable
as men that they deserve to be an
elected to public office I believe they
deserve equal pay for equal work and I
and I damn sure believe that I have done
my part to ensure that men who hurt
little girls should go to jail and not
the United States Senate okay so this is
gonna be his campaign in order for them
to make this campaign credible they had
to get rid of Franken it appears that's
now their move to get rid of Franken in
the days leading up to Moore and then if
the Republicans elect more they say well
that's because Republicans are sleaze
bags unfortunately Republicans are
falling right into the teeth of this by
actually being sleaze bags so that's not
helpful
and by sleaze bags I don't mean people
who are gonna vote for more as I've said
I think there a lot of people voting for
more because they think he's the second
worst choice I think there are a lot of
people voting for more because they
think he'll be expelled in the Senate
but if you are saying that Roy Moore is
an honorable decent human being in the
aftermath of these allegations all I
would say is that there's not a lot of
evidence to prove any of that there's
not a lot of evidence now this is
leading some Republicans to immediately
virtue signal to the furthest possible
extent Jeff Flake is one of those Jeff
Flake of course is the Republican
senator from Arizona yesterday he
tweeted out country over party and he
got what he wanted one thousand one
hundred seventy one thousand likes on
this tweet and it says Doug Jones for us
any tweet out a picture of a check he
sent to Doug Jones a hundred dollars and
said a country over party in the subject
line and then he signed a Jeff Flake you
don't have to give money to the Democrat
in order to oppose everyone okay I
opposed Doug Jones's policies I opposed
Roy Moore I've said stay home or write
somebody in don't vote for Roy Moore but
Republicans feel the necessity in order
to alleviate their own sense of cosmic
Agata dissonance and guilt as I
mentioned yesterday they feel the
necessity to fully embrace Roy Moore and
leading the way is the avatar of
Republican Satanism that of course is
Steve Bannon
so as I've said before I know Steve
really well I try not to talk about
Steve because I know Steve really well
and I think Steve is one of the worst
people I have ever met and Steve is
making that clear in Alabama so he's
doing this whole I'm a populist okay
Steve
a Goldman Sachs guy okay he's a Goldman
Sachs guy went to Harvard Business
School and he walks around dressed like
a homeless man so that he can pretend
that he's actually in touch with the
blue-collar grassroots feel of the
United States he jumped in the room or
race really late and then claimed credit
for Moore's primary victory then he
disappeared while the controversy
happened and now he's reeling only after
the RNC has Rhian door so that's your
courageous Steve Bannon but Bannon
didn't just stop there yesterday at a
rally he decided to slam Mitt Romney so
as we discussed yesterday Mitt Romney
may be one of the most honorable people
ever run for presidents of the United
States Romney came out and said you
shouldn't back more more as an alleged
child molester incredibly alleged to
child molester okay Steve Bannon took
the opportunity to bash Mitt Romney and
say that Roy Moore is a better human
than Mitt Romney right a guy who was
trolling food courts allegedly for
fifteen year olds when he was 33 is a
better person than Mitt Romney a guy
who's been married to his high school
sweetheart has led the cleanest life of
anyone imaginable in the history of
American politics and that guy's a bad
guy because we have to back Roy Moore
this is what I say that that Bannon is
just an avatar he's like the in in the
in the image in the cartoon you know
where you have the the cartoon character
and you have the devil on one shoulder
and the angel on the other
I'm not true the angel on the shoulder
is for Republicans but I know who the
devil on the shoulder is and that guy
see Bennett so the the devil on the
shoulder Steve Bannon starts ripping
into Mitt Romney well dressed like a
derelict homeless person who just got
his clothes from the Salvation Army
talking about how how Roy Moore is a
quality human being as opposed to Romney
who's a leech a Mormon leech that's
basically what he says
[Applause]
for energy yet five sons not one day of
service there's been in doing his
man-of-the-people shtick the Romney sons
didn't serve in Rock we'll play more of
it in a second the Romney sons didn't
serve in Iraq okay if we're gonna hold
that this is the standard for honor and
integrity you know who else didn't serve
in Iraq any of trumps sons you know who
didn't serve in Vietnam at Trump if
we're gonna go down this road you know
Romney got a deferment because use
Mormons who went on mission and his sons
went on mission too
the idea that you have to serve in the
military in order to be honorable if
that's the case Donald Trump had five
separate deferments from Vietnam
including four for college and one for
bad feet okay but but I don't see been
and ripping on on him that way and I
seem to recall Bannon being totally fine
with with with Trump smacking around
John McCain on his water service I don't
remember Bandhan being particularly
upset about that but then it gets even
worse then Bannon decides to to say that
that more has more honor than the entire
Romney family
[Applause]
we're at war
he says that Roy Moore first of all
Bannon is is just a terrible speaker but
beyond that he also when he says that he
what he said there it's hard to hear is
that Roy Moore has more honor and
integrity in his little finger then
stood then Mitt Romney his family has in
their entire DNA just gross just gross
I'll tell you one thing Mitt Romney has
not been credibly accused of taking a
fourteen-year-old girl home and trying
to in trying to get inside her panties
that's something that Mitt Romney has
never been credibly accused of or taking
a sixteen-year-old girl into his car
news in his 30s and attempting to grope
her breast and grab her by the genitals
but this is you know if the Republicans
want to embrace the dark side there
there's no better way to do this than
that as I say it is a Democratic
manipulation for them to suggest that
they are clean in all of this but they
are grabbing the moral high ground
because it's almost impossible for them
to grab the moral low ground away from a
Republican party that is doing the
Bandon routine again you can vote for
more and not do the Bandon routine but
there are too many Republicans who are
doing the band and routine that is going
to have some serious blowback there's
the reluctantly supporting more crowd
and then there's the band and crowd and
the band and crowd is gonna do severe
damage to the Republican brand but
Bannon doesn't care because all Bannon
cares about is his own image as a
populist firebrand even though he's been
irrelevant conman for most of his career
until he what leached on to Donald Trump
and after leeching onto Andrew Breitbart
and Breitbart stuff okay so now I want
to talk a little bit about the about the
Trump investigation and the latest on
the Trump investigation so right now
there there is there's a report
yesterday that Bank records had been
subpoenaed from Donald Trump it turns
out this was another false report from
the media so you always have to wait for
24 hours to find out what the media's
reporting is true and what the reporting
is false about President Trump White
House press secretary secretary Huckabee
Sanders on Tuesday disputed reports that
Special Counsel Robert Muller had
subpoenaed president Trump's bank
records
she said we confirmed that the news
reports that the special counsel had
subpoenaed financial reports related to
the president are completely false no
subpoena has been issued or received we
have confirmed this with the bank and
other sources I think this is another
example of the media going too far and
too fast and we don't see it going in
that direction so all of the talk about
how Trump was being subpoenaed and his
financial records were on the line that
turns out not to be true so that's a
part of the investigation that has not
yet developed meanwhile there's the the
rumor
out there from CNN that president that
vice president Pence is gonna be brought
in to talk with the FBI according to CNN
new revelations about Michael Flynn's
lies to the FBI are laying bare Vice
President Mike Pence's in the dark
strategy when it comes to Russia's
election meddling raising new questions
about whether he could have been in that
left in the dark as he has argued for
nearly a year
advisers have long insisted that pence
was unaware Flynn spoke to then Russian
ambassador to the u.s. surrogate his
lyac about a new set of US sanctions on
the day they were announced last
December but court filings unsealed last
week paired with new details about
President Trump's own knowledge of
events indicate a wide circle of
advisers were aware that Flynn raised
the issue when he spoke by phone to
Moscow as an envoy even as pence
reportedly remained in the dark
well Pence was not even in town when any
of this happened I mean that there was a
political report talking about where
pence was at the time pence was
apparently back in Indiana this entire
time so the idea that pence was sitting
on top of Mike Flynn for these phone
calls manat a lot of evidence to support
that the reason that the the media want
to get pence is because now they have to
get an active member of the
administration vice president Pence is
one of more powerful vice presidents in
recent memory in terms of helping direct
policy inside the White House and if
they get pens the suggestions going to
be how compelling Trump not as they're
trying to make the case that moves up
the chain there's not a lot of evidence
to support that as of yet most of this
looks a lot like speculation so let's
not get out over our skis I think people
are out over their skis in the media on
all of this so with all of that said
there is now breaking news that
President Obama is speaking out again so
this is exciting
President Obama just continues to talk
and talk and talk apparently he issued a
stark warning about growing nativism in
the US and throughout the world that the
Economic Club of Chicago invoking
complacency and the rise of Hitler oh
yes now we're all going to talk Hitler
Hitler Hitler make Hitler he says we
have to tend to this garden of democracy
or else things could fall apart quickly
that's what happened in Germany in the
1930s which despite the democracy of the
Weimar Republic and centuries of
high-level cultural and scientific
achievements Adolf Hitler rose to
dominate 60 million people died so
you've got to pay attention so is that
supposed to be some sort of a legal
market Trump because President Obama
does not get to make those sorts of
veiled remarks with regard to President
Trump after enabling the most nazi-like
regime on planet earth the Iranian
regime and yet that seems like exactly
what
is doing this sort of political
polarization and the attempts to
apparently throw Trump out of power via
an investigation that really has
uncovered no underlying crime thus far
you want to destabilize the United
States that's the best way to
destabilize the United States as
everyone knows I have tried to be as
objective as I can about President Trump
but I think the evidence is bad for
Trump I'll say so I think the evidence
is not bad for President Trump
I'll say so what I will not do is humor
this notion from the left that president
Trump must be deposed simply because he
is President Trump because that is crap
okay he was an elected official he was
elected to the presidency of the United
States and all of these dire warnings
about Hitler Hitler's rise ignores the
fact Hitler's rise occurred because
there was a feeling in Germany that
there was a a complete unworkability of
the of the chancellorship and the
government in Germany the dictatorship
actually pre-existed Hitler because
people were so dissatisfied they kept
handing more power to a centralized
government in Germany Hitler just
grabbed the reins of that power that is
a long process not a short process and
so for Obama to suggest that we're right
on the verge of that and then not look
in the mirror at all is is somewhat
shocking overall so with all of that
said a final piece of news here before
we have to before we have to break and
that is that there was an Islamist
suicide plot that was foiled to
assassinate Prime Minister Theresa May
according to Sky's crime correspondent
it's the latest in a number of terror
plots the police and mi5 believe they've
foiled this year I understand the head
of mi5 Andrew Parker briefed cabinet
ministers Tuesday such as the
seriousness of what they believe they
have been covered in essence there's an
extreme Islamist suicide plot against
Downing Street police believe the plan
was to launch some sort of improvised
explosive device at Downing Street and
in the ensuing chaos attack and kill
Theresa May now a mere a Zakaria Rahman
20 from North London and Mohammed Sahib
a Moran 21 from southeast Birmingham are
due to appear at Westminster
magistrate's court on terrorist charges
on Wednesday morning
so if President Obama is gonna worry
about the rise of Nazism I would suggest
that he start by worrying about the rise
of radical Islam which she radically
helped all the way through his
presidency particularly among the the
Iranian popular among with with regard
to the Iranian government so with all of
this said with all of this set I now I'm
going to take a break from Facebook and
we're going to move on but you have to
subscribe for that so go over to daily
wire.com when you do that when you
subscribe to daily wire comm then for
$9.99 a month you get this the greatest
show in all human existence live on
video you get to watch it live you also
get to watch the end of Clavin show live
you get to watch the Michael Knowles
show live it gets people hired of the
mailbag for all three shows and we're
doing our mailbag on Friday as we always
do plus we have something called the
conversation that's coming up next week
December 12th and in order for you to
ask questions in the conversation you
have to be a subscriber it's happening
at 2 p.m. Pacific 5 p.m. Eastern
December 12th that is called again the
conversation and you can be a part of it
only subscribers ask questions anyone
can watch but you have to be subscriber
to ask questions and when you ask me
those I will either answer them or mock
you so you know see if you get lucky my
conversation will stream live on the
bench Shapiro Facebook page and The
Daily wire YouTube channel it will be
free for everyone to watch but only
subscribers can ask the questions to ask
questions as a subscriber you log into
our website daily wire.com you head over
to the conversation page to watch the
live stream after that you just start
typing into the daily wired chat box and
I'll answer questions as they come for
an entire hour once again subscribe to
get your questions answered by yours
truly on Tuesday December 12 5 p.m.
Eastern 2 p.m. Pacific join the
conversation if you want all of that
Plus this the greatest in all beverage
vessels the leftist tears hot or cold
tumblr all you have to do is go over
daily wired I can't get that annual
subscription you get all of those things
plus the Shapiro store will be launching
I think it's post Christmas now it just
keeps getting pushed back post Christmas
probably but no it'll actually be
happening in the near future I know I've
been promising it for a long time but
just like the embassy it's delayed but
soon but will be gratified at a certain
point so check that out if you just want
to listen to the show later iTunes
SoundCloud please subscribe a YouTube we
have a very fun and Christmas video
that's gonna be coming out very soon so
subscribe over at YouTube as well we are
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
all righty so time for some things I
like and then some things that I hate so
things that I like
I started this series I can't say I'm
far enough in it to fully endorse it yet
but the first episode is is good and
solid it's the series godless on Netflix
it's sort of a feminist Western I think
you can say is that fair Malthus you've
seen the whole thing okay you see most
of it right so you see Angelus you're
one episode ahead of me so I don't know
so your opinion is of no consequence to
me in any case the first the first
episode is quite good Jeff Daniels is
very frightening as the bad guy
basically the idea is that there was
this mining town where all the men were
killed in a mining accident and now
there's a bad guy coming to town with
his crew and they're searching for a guy
who has robbed them and the danger is
that they may come in and kill everyone
so how does this town of women gonna
defend itself and the answer of course
is they'll all wear hats so I have
not gotten to the part where they whip
out the hats yet but I don't think
that's right I think they'll actually
show up with guns to defend themselves
making the case for the NRA the series
is godless so check that out on Netflix
it is rated R as our most of the Netflix
series that I actually recommend okay
time for some things that I hate so
thing I hate number one as I mentioned
is that the this movie the post is is
coming out I went to the theater last
night I watch Murder on the Orient
Express which I quite liked actually
there's some things I didn't like about
but I liked it overall and they showed a
preview for the post we're at some point
going to actually have to grab the video
of the post but that would be up to me
to tell my producers to do that in any
case the the actual trailer is
insufferable insufferable as I discussed
yesterday on the show but now Meryl
Streep and Steven Spielberg are doing
joint
interviews and they're talking about all
of the similarities between the Nixon
administration the Trump administration
now note there have been zero crackdowns
none on media under the Trump
administration there's not a paper
that's been put out of business there's
not a journalist that's been sued
nothing as far as I'm aware and I'm
happy to be corrected I've seen no
actual crackdown I've seen a White House
that doesn't like talking to the press
that Stonewall's the press that was true
of Obama as well the difference is that
Obama actually prosecuted members of the
press but here's Stevens Pilger said
quote I could not believe the
similarities between today and what hap
with the Nixon administration I realized
this was the only year to make this film
well what you realized that you hadn't
made a film that virtually signaled for
at least a couple of years so it's time
to make a new one
Meryl Streep talked about what she reads
she says in my political reading I read
the New York Times The Washington Post
in The Guardian shocker I check in on
political acts Axios in Drudge and I go
to Fox often to see the manipulation
right she has to make clear that she
only watches because she wants to see
how evil foxes and Spielberg talked
about some of the hosts he likes he says
I like Don Lemon I like Rachel Maddow
shocker and and there was also who else
he talking to Liz Hanna who was the
screenwriter and Amy Pascal who was the
producer and I Hannah said the bravery
Anderson Cooper has to go into war zones
is pretty admirable and then Spielberg
says yeah I adore it and follow
Christiane Amanpour Christiane Amanpour
is the worst journalist ever Christiane
Amanpour is wildly anti-israel wildly
anti-american Christiane Amanpour is
terrible but of course she's very
fashionable in the sort of leftist
circles in which Steven Spielberg walked
I'm sure it's because he watches
Christiane Amanpour that he thought the
Munich would make a good film and and
then Meryl Streep said Maggie Haberman
also I also like Maggie Herman's
Reporter said I tend to trust the women
yeah well you didn't trust the women
enough to actually stand up against
Harvey Weinstein when he had the chance
so now there's a new report out about
how everyone knew what one team was
doing including apparently he was
injecting his win wing with with
chemicals in order to make it perform
certain magical tasks and everybody knew
about he was having his assistants do it
for him so well well good good on you
Meryl you trust the woman but you had
nothing to say about any of this stuff
for years so you're a real pillar of
strength okay other things that I hate
so speaking of virtue signaling it seems
like all of these pop stars now are
coming out and saying that they want
their children to be screwed up for life
like it's their actual goal in life to
screw up their kids so pop super
superstar pink has two kids
willow who's her six-year-old daughter
and Jamison her 11 month old son who's
named after some sort of alcohol I guess
she has big dreams for them but they
don't subscribe to the idea that willow
as a girl and Jamison is a boy pink said
quote I was in a school and the bathroom
outside the kindergarten said
gender-neutral anybody and was a drawing
of many shapes I took a picture of it I
wrote progress I thought that was
awesome I love the kids are having this
conversation yes there's nothing better
for small children than being confused
as to whether they're a boy or a girl
and they can switch randomly and
arbitrarily between them that's not
with higher suicide attempts rates it's
not linked with depression sounds did
any of that stuff gender confusion is
really good for kids it's fantastic for
kids if you're insane
if you're insane part of what your job
is to do as parents is to look at what
your kids are and then attempt to make
their life easier by having them develop
in psychologically healthy ways you are
the same people who will say that we
need to teach men not to rape and that
men inherently have a tendency toward
rape we'll say that man who doesn't even
exist in a man can be a woman that's an
insane proposition okay the whole point
is that if you want men to be good you
have to acknowledge the nature of men
and then you have to teach men to be
gentleman that comes along with with a
positive masculinity the same thing is
true among women there are such a thing
as positive femininity
okay there's such a thing as toxic
femininity - I think if we're gonna talk
about toxicity toxic just meaning bad
behavior among men or bad behavior among
women to suggest that all women are
angels and all men are Devils is not the
case okay the whole point of civilizing
your children is to bring them up to be
the best man or woman they can be if
they suffer from gender confusion issues
that's something you have to deal with
but to impose gender confusion on your
child because you're so progressive is
just pathetic and sick
pink is enthused that Willow told her
she wants to marry an African woman who
when she grows up her kid is six her kid
is six
she's enthused about that like her kid
doesn't even know what she's talking
about
like her kid it doesn't even have sexual
hormones running through her at this
point and you're already talking like oh
yeah that's good if you want to be a
lesbian just go for it she's a six year
old what the hell is wrong with you and
we are very labeled as household last
week willow told me she's gonna marry an
African woman why not an Asian woman
who's her six-year-old racist and I was
like great can you teach me how to make
African food you're like sure mama and
we were going to live with you while our
house is getting ready I was like what
the f who are you who is paying for this
by the way and she said this is just
great and it is worth noting as Hank
Berrien does over at Daily wire but
after spending her prepubescent years
using ecstasy crystal meth an acid she
came close to overdosing this pink in a
club when she was 15 she apparently
think she was screwed up then but she's
much better now saying I went off the
rails before all of this I got my bleep
out of the way early before anyone knew
who I was
well why weren't you just exploring her
boundaries why was that a problem why
couldn't you just be who you want to be
you want to crystal meth when you're 15
that's fine and if you want to be a boy
when you're a girl at three what's the
problem
self-definition
subjectivism that's the ticket well now
she says I'm much more mom than I am at
anything else absolutely a hundred
percent I feel bad for a kids honestly
kids want lines kids want rules kids
want structures kids want to know that
there's a predictability in the universe
parents who fail to recognize this bring
up bad children and children even if
they're not bad who are who are troubled
and have difficulty children are looking
for lines they're unformed by
civilization it's why we formed
civilizations to make better human
beings but the left doesn't believe that
they believe that you should be able to
do whatever you want in terms of
children like children should be able do
whatever they want we don't have any
role in cultivating them and then
they're surprised when uncultivated
human beings end up doing bad things
when they grow up or end up being
troubled when they grow up okay time for
a little bit of Bible so this week I
felt that it was useful to go through
the actual portion of Genesis where
Jerusalem is first referenced according
to Jewish tradition this of course is
the section in Genesis talking about
Jacob's dream so jacob leaves bear Sheva
this is in Genesis 28 10 through 22
Jacob left Bear Sheva and he set out for
her on when he reached a certain place
he stopped for the night because the Sun
had set he took out one of the stones
there and he put it under his head he
lay down to sleep he had a dream in
which he saw stairway resting on the
earth with its top reaching to heaven
and the angels of the Lord were
ascending and descending on it there
above it stood the Lord and he said I am
the LORD thy God the father of a your of
your the God of your father Abraham and
the god of Isaac your your forefathers I
will give you and your descendants the
land on which you are standing your
descendants will be like the dust of the
earth and you'll spread out to the west
and to the east to the north and to the
south
all the peoples on earth will be blessed
through you and your offspring I'm with
you and will watch over you wherever you
go I will bring you back to this land I
will not leave you until I have done
what I have promised you God wasn't
lying for three thousand years the
Jewish people wanted to go back to the
land for three thousand years the Jewish
relation was inextricably intertwined
with the very place where Jacob was
laying his head for three thousand years
the Jewish people have had the same
dream as Jacob that there would be a
footstool for God in Jerusalem and the
Jewish people would be able to to live
there in peace that's all the Jews
you've ever wanted thank you to
President Trump for bringing that
reality closer to fruition and for
acknowledging the reality that already
exists Jacob awoke from his sleep he
said surely the Lord is in this place I
was not aware of it and he was afraid
and he said how awesome is this place
there is none other than this
none other than the house of God this is
the gate of heaven no one cares about
Jerusalem except for the Jews and that
is my Jewish sovereignty over Jerusalem
is important it's also the foundation
the same Jews that brought Jerusalem
forth brought forth the basis of Western
civilization and we would not have the
civilization we have without those words
in the book of Genesis and it's great to
acknowledge the legitimacy of those
words from the white house I'll have
much more to discuss tomorrow lots of
breaking news as always I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show the Ben
Shapiro show is produced by Mathis
Glover executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hay our
technical producer is Austen Stevens
edited by Alex zingaro audio is mixed by
Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by Jess
while opera the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for publishing 2017